[Music]
daryl is in new york city to start off
this hour hi daryl how are you
hi dave i'm good um thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um my wife and i uh we're in contract to
um buy a new apartment and we're trying
to
tell our old apartment but we're having
a tough time
um selling it so we're kind of sitting
with a couple of options
and in order to raise the money to do
the closing
um so we can either flash the price
of our apartment and just like take a
loss on it
i have an inherited ira for my mom
that i can liquidate and pay tax on in
order to fund it and my wife has
some stock options that are investing in
november
that we can possibly use but it wouldn't
cover all of it it would cover about
half so just trying to or we can just
walk away actually because um there's a
cause in the contract that would give us
the ability to kind of walk away from
the new apartment
you're not gonna like my answer daryl
oh boy
um you're forcing
yourself into a corner
if you own two properties
because you refused to deny
yourself new one
so either your house sells or you've cut
bait
got it got it
what is your what is your current
property on the market for
uh we we put it on for um 8.25
what is it what is it actually worth
i mean
what would some goob give for it but
what's it actually worth
i i would say probably about um 750 for
being realistic about it okay so you
were fishing for a sucker fish
yeah there's this with 421a abatement
in new york city where property taxes i
know i know but you're but you were
fishing for it's not even with the
abatement it's worth 750.
yeah yeah and so what we're really
saying is because i won't try to sell my
current property for what it's actually
worth
uh i want to get i want to get a premium
above what it's worth then i've got to
look at am i cashing out something and
creating a taxable situation or am i
going to borrow money or what am i going
to do now cut your property to what it's
worth and sell the stupid thing and if
it doesn't sell let the other one go
okay that's what i would do
it's uh but what i am just describing is
very emotional
because what i just did is i stuck a pen
in your little dream
and blew it up
yeah and it's hard because i i mean i
use my inheritance to make the deposit
so just loot like you're going to lose
that i thought you said you had an out
in the contract
well i no well
um to put the deposit when i originally
bought this home it was 150 000. i got
some life insurance and uh i use that as
a down the down payment on this property
no you didn't do a down payment because
you're closed on it you mean you put up
an earnest money of 150 000
no the the the property
the property we own now the new one we
saved and and put the money we saved all
our bonuses and things
to put the down payment on that i'm just
talking about the one that we own now
you don't have a down payment on
something unless you own it have you
already closed on the second property
no we haven't closed on it okay then
it's not a down payment it's an earnest
money so all the equity yeah the equity
that we have in this in this apartment
is the inheritance i put in
basically on the current one
that's what i'm saying
okay let's separate the two for a second
you have a contract on the second deal
that has a contingency in it that allows
you to not close correct
that's right you would not lose your
deposit on that property if that
contract has that kind of contingency
that's correct okay so you're going to
get all that money back
if you don't close and you'll be living
in your original property and that is
heartbreaking because your mind and your
sweet tooth is already set on the new
place
agreed that's right okay now i agree
what did you pay for
the current property that you are living
in
um 765 and then we we redid the kitchen
for 25 000. okay so you've got almost
800 in it but it's not worth that
that's right okay so you're going to
lose your kitchen remodel money but
you're not going to lose 150 000
by selling the same thing for 750 or
760.
yeah there's just a lot of seo brokers
and all that stuff but yeah
yeah i will walk away with something it
just won't be like you know what we
wanted so
what you wanted was more than it was
worth
yeah
so what you wanted was unrealistic how
long have you owned your current
apartment
uh and we bought in 2017 so it's been
about
four years four or five years
okay
what's your household income
uh we're we're at about 530 000. way to
go man um
i you can do what you want to do you
called here and asked so i'm obligated
to answer number one i wouldn't close on
the deal unless the other one's gone
under any circumstances
number two there's a whole lot of things
i'm hearing in this conversation that
makes me think you impulsed your butt
off on this second purchase
and now you're stuck in it and you're
emotionally stuck in it um i think it
might be
likely is wise
for you to just cancel the other deal
and enjoy your current million dollar
property for a little while
and sit there and make 550 and pile you
up a big old pile of cash let the value
of that thing come on up a little more
so you're not having to hold your nose
when you sell it
live in it another year two and then
make a move on a much more wise more
solid footing than you're making right
now i think y'all were out wandering
around one day and saw an open house and
bought a house that's what it feels like
yeah and especially with his income he
could probably save up to a really a
long position pretty quickly those stock
options come in a lot of other things
come in you're forcing this
you're forcing it if it's all over it
and it feels very impulsive feels very
um
it doesn't feel like it was executed
with a plan
and um so i i would not tell you under
any circumstances to own both of these
properties so one of them has got to go
you need to get the one you're living in
sold and just bite the bullet and say
that's it i really want the other one so
badly my wife really wants the other one
so badly that i'm willing to lose
whatever i lose on that and i'm out of
there and i'm going to go buy the other
one
and then we're going to keep making 550
we're going to get the stock options
we'll get it paid off pretty quick
you're going to be in good shape either
way
but it won't hurt you to sit in this one
another 18 to 24 months and look for
another deal
it won't at all it won't at all but i
would never tell i never tell people to
buy two houses at once to own two houses
at once this happened one of one foot on
the boat one on the dock the dock's
leaving your butt's gonna get wet
that's what's gonna happen you're gonna
fall in
and that
man i've watched that for 30 years
happen over and over and over again
and you could get away with a lot of
that stuff when the market was quite hot
and crazy like he listed that thing at
white hot crazy prices the auction
prices and didn't get it those days as
we can tell are starting to go away